hey dr. Berg here in this short video  we're going to talk about a product  called organic seek help  organic seek help is made from the the  ocean in Iceland so it's probably one of  the purest places on the planet that you  can grow sea kelp and it's a 1%  certified organic so there's no  pesticides or anything like that in it  but it's a high quality iodine product  that is a plant based and it has a lot  of other things in it like selenium and  boron and a lot of the other trace  minerals that are in the sea but it's  all plant base it has 500 milligrams so  I recommend this to support a healthy  thyroid gland I also use this to support  a healthy ovaries support healthy breast  tissue so it's good for all the female  organs and it's very very high quality  so if you're looking for a sea kelp and  you want something more vegetarian this  is the one to try